we have to talk about joe biden's
biggest broken promise so far
now many of you might think i'm going to
talk about the lack of a coveted
stimulus bill
so far and that is quickly going in the
failure direction but we all knew that
it could take
some time to get it done i do think
enough time has gone by it's time to get
covered relief
done without republicans do it through
budget reconciliation
and we've been talking about that but in
any case what i believe
is biden's biggest failure so far is joe
biden's failed
promise on stopping the deportation of
undocumented immigrants through these
removal flights
that were prevalent under donald trump
until we can actually get immigration
policy
fixed so first of all what is going on
if you haven't been following the story
i understand you may not know what's
going on joe biden
promised to stop deportations until
immigration policy could be fixed now he
did
try via an executive order but
unfortunately a trump appointed judge
in texas quickly blocked the biden
administration's executive order
to do a 100-day deportation moratorium
and the deportations are happening
just as they were happening under donald
trump last week ice carried out
21 removal flights to six different
countries now it could be easy
for some on the left maybe you're
thinking this david hold on
joe biden did his executive order he
promised to do an executive order and he
did
and a judge blocked it biden tried his
hands are tied
sadly in this case that explanation just
isn't good enough
the judge that blocked joe biden's halt
to deportations
blocked it on very specific legal
grounds and joe biden could immediately
do
another executive order or even multiple
executive orders
with different justifications that legal
experts believe
would be far more difficult for a judge
to block
without getting into all the details
here the gist of this
is that because many of these
deportations are happening under what's
called title 42
that's an entire swath of circumstances
that could stop the deportations
because many legal experts and
immigration advocates believe that title
42 removals which are all
premised under the guise of stopping the
spread of covet removing people
to stop the spread of covid many legal
experts and immigration activists
believe that those provisions are under
uh
are against international refoulement
laws that they're not racially equitable
and each of these claims of course is
its kind of own legal morass
but the point is that it's not nearly as
simple as listen
joe signed an executive order and a
judge blocked it
and that's it i believe that there's a
huge moral
urgency to do this and if indeed it
wasn't just
one of a list of calculated promises
that joe biden made
they need to just be cranking out
executive order
after executive order to get the
deportation stopped
it is unlikely that there would be uh
legal mechanisms to stop
every single one of these justifications
and
uh i believe that it should be done now
how much longer until this is dealt with
what is acceptable i think that we are
beyond it and so for me this is joe
biden's
uh biggest failure so far followed
closely behind
the slow progress on the coveted relief
bill which they need to get done
it needs to happen today and if not
tomorrow and it should have happened a
couple of weeks ago
republicans don't want to play ball let
them vote against it
pass it via budget reconcilia
reconciliation i've been talking about
it for weeks now
but i am not yet calling that the
biggest failure i believe the
immigration failure is the biggest one
so far
if you disagree with me or you agree or
you're not sure
or you have some other failure that you
think is the biggest failure so far
let me know you can find me on twitter
deepakman and again
if you're just going to email me and say
david joe biden needs time
he promised to do this right away he did
the executive order it was blocked
many legal experts agree do another
executive order with a different
justification this can be done
how committed to it is the biden
administration we will soon see
find me on twitter at dpakman one of our
sponsors is
magic spoon magic spoon breakfast cereal
sweet and delicious like the cereals you
had as a kid
without the sugar magic spoon tastes
exactly
like the cereal brands we all know and
loved as kids
but it has no sugar only three net carbs
and 13 grams of protein perfect for
anyone following a keto or low carb diet
or just anybody wanting to eat less
sugar comes in frosted fruity cocoa
and their all new flavor peanut butter
that's my favorite magic spoon flavor
or you can get a variety pack so you can
try all four
magic spoon is so confident in how
delicious their cereal is
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't absolutely
love it they'll give you five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video